[Musique]
quoique tu une appétence pour les
territoires gens vont aller vers
l'espace de recherche aujourd'hui
d'avoir nouveaux horizons mais pour que
ça fonctionne pour qu'il y ait pour que
ça ce match il faut bien évidemment
pouvoir proposer aux habitants de notre
pays des services à maintien des classes
à réseaux de communication des rays à la
hauteur à réseaux de communication
fibres et téléphonie et puis aussi des
services de proximité professionnels de
santé & commerce est donc dans cette
mission au titre de l'aménagement du
territoire mais nous regardons comment
pouvoir pérenniser donner un avenir aux
commerçants millions de fans
avec le e-commerce la problématique de
la logistique urbaine se pose avec
beaucoup d'acuité il y a de plus en plus
de demandes beaucoup plus de transport
de marchandises qu'il n'y en avait avant
et donc ce que nous espérons mettons de
la durabilité dans la logistique urbaine
est bien c'est de causer moins
d'embouteillages moins de bruit moins de
pollution moins de particules fines et
les utilisateurs on va dire du
e-commerce y trouveront également un
bénéfice avec ce cette qualité de vie
retrouvée
bilan et n'est malheureusement pas
favorable 6,6 le sénat se penche à
nouveau sur ce sujet là c'est bien que
nous n'avons rien réglé de ce qui se
passe depuis plus que plusieurs années
il faut savoir que pratiquement la
dernière dernier sondage 59 % des
français interrogés dire qu'ils ont
renoncé à certains soins parce
qu'effectivement il avait un problème
d'accès à ces à ses soins il faut aussi
voir que on arrive pratiquement à 6
millions de français qui n'ont plus de
médecins traitants et les chiffres
malheureusement ne font qu'empirer
nous sommes partis du constat que 14
millions de français maîtrisez très mal
tous les outils numériques
c'est un sujet qui est
connu de tous d'ailleurs il y à un
foisonnement d'initiatives
qu'elles soient publiques ou privées en
la matière la problématique en fait
c'est un peu le maquis et le
foisonnement de ces aides qui ne sont
pas lisibles des français qui en ont
besoin la problématique vient aussi
d'une stratégie nationale difficilement
lisible par rapport à ce sujet et puis
aussi malheureusement le manque de
moyens bien que des initiatives ont été
faites sur le sujet bien évidemment